yeah yeah how you been uh since last
time it's been how many months now since
been
10 yeah it's been good I've um I've done
so many things since retiring from
teaching which was kind of the point of
the last episode congratulations congrat
traveled the world and saw Paris twice I
love I'm so sorry yeah oh I'm I'm not
sorry anymore we were notorious France
haters on this podcast sorry France well
the parisians have a friend in me
because I thought it was excellent but I
will say my favorite parts of being in
Paris was eating outside or having you
know a beer um like overlooking and
watching people and everyone says that's
just a worse Italy that's and I said
okay well I haven't been to Italy then
not wrong well I thought it was cool and
I like should like a very European thing
eat Out outdoors and summer especially
and I think twitchcon is normally EU is
in Sumer right uh yes it was very very
common yeah I loved Paris I like how
they have the uniformity of the building
codes it makes for a nice night walk and
the the lighting at night in Paris is
undefeated is this your first time in
Europe yes okay and I haven't visited
anywhere else you went to
the you went went to the UK which is on
the continent of Europe no yeah but you
guys didn't want to be a part of it so
it's like hey don't don't blame me I'm
just saying I Mainland Europe I've only
been to one place so Mainland Europe he
still in Europe I mean the the greater
yeah but I mean it was it was fun you
ate good food personably you I'm almost
jealous you had a good time in Paris it
was great both times so you went twice
once was for recreation just for you
know just just on my own the second was
for twitchcon okay and uh but yeah this
past year has been a whole different
world of getting to collaborate with
others and do Adventures that were
otherwise unavailable to me due to a
teaching schedule so I've been a lucky
guy this past year oh yeah man yeah it's
been great
good stuff it seems like you've
definitely kind of like do like Dove
straight head first into quitting
teaching and the creat life and going
into like the Creator life we're so
sorry that uh what a mistake one of us
now yeah my my mother was so proud of me
and now she's like you talk on camera
I'm like yeah Mom it's amazing she's
like I don't like watching it like all
right so your mom doesn't say that no
she can't figure out what twitch is yet
I've sent to the my parents I've sent it
to them like five times I it took like
the 10th attempt for them to finally
like actually click it and figure out
what twitch was well and it was
different from YouTube it's very
different and my mom's she's 73 God
bless her and she chose the name gypsy
girl
5057 and uh and so now people when she's
typing I can see Chatters being like
what's up Gypsy I was like don't talk to
my mom like that she's not a gypsy girl
she's not why did she choose [__] I don't
know she's just really in tune with like
that kind of whole traveling and kind of
I don't know what that's what she chose
okay and uh but she she could have just
chosen well she's got to she's got to
change her username now that you just
said that on camera well she's not there
enough so it's okay she's not she's not
there enough wait she next time though
you're streaming and she's in the chat
everyone's going to be like hey
yo mom I'd rather it be out that it's
not no one can hit on her or talk to her
differently so let leave her alone oh
yes I was most certainly going to hit on
Gypsy
girl7 you have to sorry yeah it's cool
to for my family to not understand what
I'm doing it's kind of awesome so I
don't know it's kind of nice though when
they're like you do what and you're like
yeah it's kind of weird but it's fun I
kind of like the almost you know you're
kind of carving your own Mist kind way
very satisfying for sure the only tricky
part and maybe you guys can relate to
this given some of the topics that
you've discussed on this channel to have
like close family members like your your
mom sisters or something and then they
watch a clip of you talking about some
sort of titty anime you're like well I
can I can defend this it it's weird to
talk about stuff that is kind of
immature and then have like your uncle
yeah but that this is the Assumption
Pete that you that my family has great
expectations of me which they most
certainly do not the moment I said I
want to be a YouTuber fulltime it just
went downhill they like all right of
course he's talking about anime it's
whatever I feel like my parents have
gone through an entire character Arc
that they've just not told me about of
like acceptance they've gone through
like the five stages of grief and I've
just seen the acceptance SP of it but my
parents just don't mention it they just
don't mention it they just don't mention
it they're like we really like what you
do 95% of the time we don't we don't
talk about the other the other 5% that's
a SM way of doing just turning the Blind
Eye yeah like well kind of pays the
bills does your do your parents still
say yeah my son he's a uh he's a
lifeguard do they just go to like the
last job no no no they they they like
that I do YouTube I it's something you
can I think my grandma my grandma says
that I'm a
comedian which is the biggest stretch in
the world no comedian works cuz I get
clowned sometimes you know I'm just
doing stuff like that but yeah well must
do why do you have to tell people you
don't do this Jo no no no no I I don't
think anybody asks but uh and the main
thing is I um I think that my family is
intrigued by and it helps that I'm so
far away in Japan they think it's a
phase I certainly I'm 40
G it's
a first of all I can assume and I feel
like I'm getting this as you get older
people just stop caring what you're
doing like you've you have to have
figured it out by now I don't care like
as long as you're not ruining your life
is character it's fine no one is no
one's the main character character so
yeah I think it's an amusing little
Quirk that I've gone full-time into
playing video games and and talking
about you know stuff on the internet hey
man that's the dream Joel for a long it
is the dream J I'm impressed cuz you you
managed to even adapt to a streamer
sleep schedule many times sometimes I'll
see I'll wake up in the morning and
Pete's been on for 9 hours and I'll be
like wait it's you say you're 40y old
I've seen I've seen like your lifetimes
I'm like there's no way this man is 40
years old I think even from a young age
I've always preferred the nocturnal
hours to daytime I've always enjoyed
being awake all night true gamer right
here but like like you said I've been
playing games since they came they were
invented so that hand in hand goes with
nighttime I beta tested like rock paper
scissors it was just like rock rock and
then we were like okay of sh
one of these days but it's been wait for
the theory videos like how old is Pete
really yeah it's if we go back in
time but yeah it's I've always preferred
those hours anyway so this is a perfect
job for someone like me yeah did you did
you ever stuer from like insomnia or
anything like that or is it just
something where you just found more
comfort in the night time is it just
natural to you it's just natural and so
like even some of the jobs I had in
before even coming to Japan were like
the overnight shift at these places or
or The Late Late sh the graveyard shifts
plus you know I think like true Gamers
and true nerds will unite in knowing
that well I guess it's gotten easier now
but in the old days at school there was
no smartphones or tablets or laptops so
you all of your nerd [__] had to be done
in between the hours of like 6:00 p.m.
and 3:00 a.m. before you went to school
the next day I think all of us were kind
of in the same yeah I think so right I
didn't have access I just don't have the
energy to do it nowadays oh well I hit
11 p.m. and I'm like [__] it's I can I
can easily go till 4: or 5 but you the
thing that sucks is I really really hate
this this sobering moment when you're
like a I should probably get oh it's
light outside I love that I hate that I
love it all the breakfast menu is open
oh Noh I guess it's just I mean it is
slightly haunting when you when you
leave your dark room and then you go
outside and it's it's 900 a.m. yeah yeah
people have already gone to work uh oh
my God I just like I I remember having
this sobering moment where I think we
did like all night karaoke or something
like that and you know the sun had come
out it was like the uh getting the last
train and I just like I was just looking
at everyone walking past me and I
[__] despised everyone cuz I was like
[__] these people with an adequate
amount of sleep in their body right now
that should have been me and I think
that was the last time it sounds like an
amazing idea until you actually do it
yeah and then the next morning you're
like [__] I shouldn't have done that
yeah just wake up at 2 p.m. then you
know so just just adjust your sleeping
times but not what every motivational
video under the sunet they get up at
like 3:00 a.m. last
month
hours well I guess I'm just unorthodox
in my approach to anything I've ever
done so I like it has twitch changed
much uh has live streaming changed any
amount since you were last on or
anything significant you've re relations
youve had or since I started streaming
or Twitch in general since you started
streaming um no full time she been
pretty smooth sailing well I mean it's
not smooth sailing I guess but for me
it's it's I I hearken back to more of
like the older days of twitch which is
kind of more you know let's plays and
like hanging out I kind of try to
imagine that I'm just having a game
night or a land party at and it just so
happens that everyone is there with me
and I know that twitch has changed a lot
with like doing events and having these
these kind of cool things but for me
I've had the similar approach when it's
my channel just to kind of enjoy that
stuff so keeping it casual yeah yeah
it's been great fun yeah I really like
it I would not change this job for
anything it's a pretty nice job just
getting to play your favorite game y all
games you hate it's been some of your
favorite games that you've been able to
share with the world on stream this is
this is so bad because the games that I
want to Champion it's not the for TT
they're not buil for twitch and it's
it's it's I get labeled a lot as a retro
streamer and I'm really not because I
play a lot of modern games but I think I
swear I swear not not being those
allegations no but I I think of the
people who are in Japan I might be the
only one who does stream retro more
often than not so that's all I get but
games like hideo kojima's snatcher
Monkey Island all the old from our from
our generation My Generation you played
them though I never played Monkey Island
oh Monkey Island
is a great game too much talking really
for me you you get to voice act them
though there's no there's no voice so
yeah one thing that I'm impressed by is
that you always are voice acting all all
the characters on The Stream which is
which is fun but also for me it's very
exhausting to voice act all the
characters oh but you love that [__]
don't you and also I I hate voicing like
uh if there's a as a woman character my
range is just not that of such where I
could do it comfortably at all well
that's going to be a given given that we
we are we have such deep voice back when
I was streaming I used to use that as an
excuse to practice M but voice act woman
my my range is just would be very brutal
being like that's a [__] voice and I'll
be like all right let's not do that and
to me like I'm I'm sitting there and I'm
like there's a character that I feel
like is really in in my my range and I
can really give it a really good crack
and I'm like yes this the thought of
having to end this lineage right here
and then I go to oh jeez I don't know
and I'm like I'm like and I'm like oh my
God this is just like the dichotomy
between me giving a really like trying
to do this voice well and then having to
be like I'm I'm in the same can of fed I
I love doing also typically I I whenever
I've done games or I've done uh whatever
anime I'm never the main character in
these types of my voice is generally not
main character material um so the main
character is always like yeah let's do
it and it's just like this doesn't
really work then when the villain comes
on I'm like all right let's go you get
to be you get to decide what all these
guys sound and so that's that that is
the best part and obviously any woman
voice that I've ever done unless it's
like the the secretary that I used the
same voice for my mom where it's like
you know Ghostbusters what do you want
like that's fine I can get away with
that one game but the most universally
hated voice that I I think sounds
accurate but everybody seems to disagree
as my any child in any video game I give
the same voice and it sounds like this
you guys can be the official okay let's
it's not that
impressive CL my eyes I'm closing my
eyes just imagine I'm like six okay
okay that's [__] awful that's how
kids talk I've never met a kid
that's in the [__]
Sopranos you sound like Marge goling
water kid voices did that kick just like
pack away like a pack of malur I think
that's 100% Canon so it's like the the
average Kansas City
kid still sell newspapers
smoking all right well I guess that's a
loss but um I I'm not changing or
budging from that voice I mean it's
funny when you did it but imagining a
whole stream of you doing that I can
imagine could get a big grading that's
why I lost so many followers no but uh
but yeah other than voice acting and and
twitch things um you never know how long
these careers are going to last because
they're so finite of course and so I
just I just hope that as I have with all
the weird careers and jobs that I've had
I hope this one leads to something
satisfying as well by its natural
conclusion